you are one of the great historians of
our time respected sometimes
controversial
you have flourished in some of the best
universities in the world from nyu to
london school of economics to harvard
and now to hoover institution at
stanford
before we talk about the history of
money war and power
let us talk about a new university
you're part of launching here in austin
texas
it is called university of austin uatx
what is its mission its goals its plan
i think it's
pretty obvious
to a lot of people in higher education
that there's a problem
and that problem manifests itself in a
great many different ways
but i would sum up the problem as being
a drastic
chilling of the atmosphere
that constrains free uh speech free
exchange even free thought
and i had never anticipated that this
would happen in my lifetime my academic
career began in oxford in the 1980s when
anything went one sensed that a
university was a place where one could
risk
saying the unsayable and
debate the undebatable
so the fact that
in a relatively short space of time
a variety of ideas critical race theory
or wokism whatever you want to call it a
variety of ideas have come along
that seek to limit and quite drastically
limit what we can talk about
strikes me as deeply unhealthy
and i'm not sure and i've thought about
this for a long time you can fix it with
the existing institutions
i think you need to create a new one and
so after much deliberation
we decided to do it and i think uh it's
a hugely
timely opportunity
to do what people used to do in this
country which was to create new
institutions i mean that used to be the
default setting of america we sort of
stopped doing that i mean i look back
and i thought why why why are there no
new universities or at least if there
are why do they have so little impact
it seems like we have the billionaires
uh we have the need let's do it so you
still believe
in institutions in the university in the
ideal of the university i believe
passionately in that ideal
there's a reason they've been around for
nearly a millennium
there is a
a unique
thing that happens on a university
campus when it's done right and that is
the transfer of knowledge between
generations
that is a very sacred activity and it
seems to
withstand major changes in technology so
this
form that we call the university
predates the printing press
survived the printing press
continued to function through the
scientific revolution the enlightenment
uh the industrial revolution
to this day
and i think it's because
maybe because of evolutionary psychology
we need to be together
in one
relatively confined space
when we're in our late teens and early
20s for the knowledge transfer between
the generations to happen
that's my feeling about this but in
order for it to work well
there need to be very few
there needs to be a sense that one can
take intellectual risk remember
people in their late teens and early 20s
are adults but they're inexperienced
adults and
if i look back on my own time as an
undergraduate saying stupid things was
my mo
my way to finding
good ideas was through a minefield of
bad ideas
i feel so sorry
for my
for people like me today people age 18
19 20 today
who are
uh intellectually very curious ambitious
but inexperienced because
the minefields today are absolutely
lethal and you know one wrong food and
it's cancellation i said this to peter
thiel the other day
imagine being asked now i mean we were
obnoxious
undergraduates
there's nothing
that peter did at stanford that andrew
sullivan and i were not doing at oxford
uh and perhaps we were even worse
but it was so so not career ending to be
to be an absolutely insufferable
obnoxious
undergraduate then
today if we if we if people like us
exist today they must live in a state of
of constant anxiety that they're going
to be
outed for some heretical
statement that they made five years ago
on social media so
part of what motivates me is that it's
the desire to give
uh
the means of today a shot at free
thinking and
really
i i'd call it
uh
aggressive learning
learning where you're really pushed
and i just think that stopped happening
on the the major campuses because
whether at harvard where i used to teach
or at stanford where i'm now based i
i sense a kind of suffocating atmosphere
of self-censorship
that that means people are afraid to
take even minimal risk in in class i
mean just just take for example a survey
that was published
earlier this year that revealed this is
of undergraduates in four-year programs
in the us
85 percent of self-described liberal
students said they would report a
professor to the university
administration if he or she said
something they considered offensive and
something like 75 percent said said they
do it to a fellow undergraduate that's
the kind of culture that's evolved in
our universities so we need a new
university in which none of that is true
in which you can speak your mind say
stupid things get it completely wrong
and live to
to tell the tale there's a lot more
going on i think because when you start
thinking about what's wrong with a
modern university many many more things
suggest themselves and i think there's
an opportunity here to build something
that's radically new in in some ways and
radically traditional in other ways for
example i have a strong preference for
the tutorial system that you see at
oxford and cambridge which is small
group teaching
and
and highly socratic in its structure i
think it'd be great to bring that to the
united states where it doesn't really
exist but at the same time i think we
should be doing
some very 21st century things
making sure that while people are
reading and studying classic works
they're also going to be immersed in the
real world
of technological innovation a world that
you know very well
and i'd love to get a synthesis
of the ancient and classical which we're
gradually letting
fade away with the novel
uh and technological so we we want to
produce people who can simultaneously
talk intelligently
about adam smith or for that matter
shakespeare or proust
and
have a conversation with you about where
a.i is going and how long it will be
before i can get driven
here by
a self-driving vehicle allowing me to
have my lunch and prepare rather than
focus on the other crazy people on the
road so that's the dream that we can
create something which is you know
partly classical and partly 21st century
and we look around and we don't see it
if you if you don't see an institution
that you really think should exist i
think you have a more responsibility to
create it
so you're thinking including
something bigger than just liberal
education also including science
engineering and technology i should also
comment
that
you know i mostly stay out of politics
and out of some of these
aspects of liberal education that kind
of been the most controversial and
difficult within the university
but there is
a kind of ripple effect of
fear within that space
into science and engineering and
technology
that i think
has uh has a nature that's difficult to
describe it's it doesn't have a
controversial nature it just has a
nature of fear where you're not
you know you're not just saying stupid
stuff as a young 20 year old
you know
for example
deep learning machine learning is really
popular in the computer science now as
an approach for creating artificial
intelligence systems it's
it is controversial in that space to say
that
anything against machine learning saying
so sort of exploring ideas that saying
this is going to
lead to a dead end
now
that that takes some guts to do as a
young 20 year old within uh within a
classroom to think like that to raise
that question in a machine learning
course it sounds ridiculous because it's
like who's going to
uh complain about this but the the fear
that starts
in uh in a course on history
or on the
some course that covers society the fear
ripples and affects those students that
are asking big out of the box questions
about engineering about computer science
and there's a lot you know there's like
linear algebra that's not going to
change
but then there's like applied linear
algebra which is machine learning and
that's when
robots and
real systems touch human beings and
that's when you have to ask yourself
these difficult questions about
about humanity even in engineering and
science and technology courses and these
are not separate worlds in two senses
i've just
taken delivery of my copy of the book
that eric schmidt and henry kissinger
have
co-authored on artificial intelligence
the central question of which is what
does this mean for us broadly
but they're not separate worlds
you know in cp snow's sense of you know
the chasm between science and arts
because on a university campus
everything is contagious from a novel
coronavirus to the behaviors that are
occurring
in the english department
those behaviors if denunciation becomes
a norm
you know undergraduate denounces
professor teaching assistant denounces
undergraduate those behaviors are
contagious and will spread inexorably
first to social science and then to
natural sciences and i think that's
that's part of the reason why when this
started to happen when we started to get
the origins of
disinvitation and council culture
it was not just a few conservative
professors in the humanities who had to
worry everybody had to worry because
eventually
it was going to come
even to the most apparently
hard stem part of the the campus it's
it's contagious this is something
nicholas christakis should look at
because he's very good at looking at the
way in which
social networks like the ones that exist
in a university can spread everything
but i think when when we look back and
ask why did wokism spread so rapidly and
rapidly out of humanities into other
parts of universities and why did it
spread across the country and beyond the
united states to the other
english-speaking universities it's
because it's a contagion
and these behaviors are contagious
the president of a university i won't
name said to me that he receives every
day at least one
denunciation one call for somebody or
other to be fired for something that
they said that's the crazy kind of
totalitarianism light
that now exists in our uh our
universities
and of course the people who want to
downplay this say oh well there only
have been 100 and something in
disinvitations or oh there really aren't
that many cases but the point is that
the famous events the events that get
the attention
are responsible for a general chilling
that as you say spreads to every part of
the university and creates a
very familiar culture in which people
are afraid to say what they think
self-censorship look at the heterodox
academy data on this
grows and grows so now a majority of
students will say this is clear from the
latest heterodox academy surveys we are
scared to say what we think in case we
get denounced in case we get cancelled
but that's just not the correct
atmosphere
for a university in a free society
to me what's really
creepy is how many of the behaviors i
see on university campuses today are
reminiscent of the way that people used
to behave in the soviet union or in the
soviet bloc or in maui's china
the sort of totalitarianism light that i
think would we're contending with here
which manifests itself as
denunciations people informing on
superiors
some people using it for career
advantage
other people reduced to hapless
desperate apology
to try to exonerate themselves people
disappearing
metaphorically if not literally all of
this is so reminiscent
of the totalitarian regimes that i
studied earlier in my career that it
makes me feel sick and what makes me
really feel sick is that the people
doing this stuff the people who write
the letters of denunciation are
apparently unaware that they're behaving
exactly like people in stalin's soviet
union they don't know that
so they clearly have there's been a
massive educational failure if somebody
can write an anonymous or non-anonymous
letter of denunciation and not feel
shame i mean you should feel morally
completely contaminated as you are doing
that but but people haven't been taught
the realities of totalitarianism
for all these reasons i think you need
to try at least to create a new
institution
where those pathologies will be
structurally excluded
so
maybe a difficult question maybe you'll
push back on this
but you're widely seen politically as a
conservative
hoover institution is politically
what is the role of politics at the
university of austin because some of the
ideas people listening to this when they
hear the ideas you're expressing
they may think there's a lien to these
ideas there's a conservative lean to
these ideas is there such a lien
there will certainly be people who say
that because the
standard mode of
trying to discredit any new initiative
is to say oh this is a sinister
conservative uh
plot
but one of our uh co-founders heather
hying is definitely not a conservative
uh she's as committed to the idea of
academic freedom as i am but i think on
political issues we probably agree on
almost nothing
and at least i
i would guess but but politics max weber
made this point a long time ago
the politics really should stop at the
threshold of the the classroom of the
lecture hall and in my career i've
always tried to make sure that when i'm
teaching
it's not
clear where i stand politically
though of course undergraduates and
insatiably curiously want to know but it
shouldn't be clear from what i say
because indoctrination
on a political basis is an abuse of the
power of the professor as weber rightly
said
so i think one of the key principles of
of the university of austin will be that
barbarian principle that politics is not
an appropriate uh
subject for
the lecture hall for the classroom
and we should pursue truth
and enshrine
liberty of thought
if that's a political issue then i can't
help you i mean if you're against
freedom of thought then we don't really
have much of a discussion to have
and clearly there are some people who
politically seem quite hostile to it but
my sense is that there are plenty of
people on the left in academia i think
of that interesting partnership between
cornell west and robbie george
which has been institutionalized in the
academic freedom alliance it's
bipartisan this issue it really really
is after all
50 years ago it was the left that was in
favor of free speech
the right still has an anti-free speech
element to it look how quickly they're
out to ban critical race theory critical
race theory won't be banned at the
university of texas workism won't be
banned
everything will be up for discussion but
the rules of engagement will be clear
chicago principles those will be
enforced
and if you have to give a lecture on
well let's just take a recent example uh
the dorian abbott case if you're giving
a lecture
on
astrophysics
but it turns out that in some different
venue you express skepticism about
affirmative action well it doesn't
matter it's irrelevant we want to know
what your thoughts are on astrophysics
because that's what you're supposed to
be doing a lecture on that used to be
understood i mean at the oxford of the
1980s there were communists and there
were ultratories
at cambridge there were people who were
so reactionary that they celebrated
franco's birthday but they were also out
and out communists down the road at
king's college
the understanding was that that kind of
intellectual diversity was part and
parcel of university life and frankly
for undergraduate it was great fun to
cross the road and go from
you know outright conservatism ultra
tourism to communism one learns a lot
that way
but the issue is when you're promoting
or hiring or tenuring people
their politics is not relevant it really
isn't
and when it started to become relevant
and i remember this coming up at the
harvard history department late in my
time there i felt deeply deeply uneasy
that we were having conversations
that amounted to
well we can't heart x person despite
their obvious
academic qualifications because
of some political
issue
that that's not what should happen at a
healthy university
some practical questions
will university of austin be a physical
in-person university or virtual
university what are some uh
in that aspect where the classroom is it
will be a real space institution
there may be an online
dimension to it because there clearly
are a lot of things that you can do
via the internet but the core activity
of of teaching and learning i think
requires real space and i've i've
thought about this a long time debated
sebastian throne about this many many
years ago when he was a complete
believer in let's call it the
metaversity to go with the metaverse i
mean the metaversity was going to happen
wasn't it but i never really believed in
the metaversity i didn't do moocs
because i just didn't think you'd a be
able to retain the attention b be able
to cope with the scale scaled grading
that was involved i think there's a
reason universities have been around in
that their form for about a millennium
you kind of need to all be in the same
place so i think answer to that question
definitely a campus in the austin area
that's where we'll start
and if we can
allow some of our content to be
available online great we'll certainly
do that
another question is what kind of courses
and programming will it offer is that
something you can speak to what's your
vision here
we think that we need to begin
more like a startup than
like a full service university from day
one so our vision is that we start with
a summer school
which will offer provocatively the
forbidden courses we we want
i think to begin by giving
a platform
to the professors who've been most
subject to council culture and also to
give an opportunity to students who want
to hear them to come so we'll start with
the summer school that will be
somewhat in the tradition of uh of those
institutions in the interwar period that
were havens for refugees so we're we are
dealing here with the internal refugees
of uh of the work era
we'll start there uh it'll be an
opportunity to test out some
uh some content see what uh students
will come uh
and spend time in austin to hear so
that's part a that's the sort of uh
if if you like the launch product and
then we go straight to a masters uh
program
i don't think you can go to
undergraduate education right away
because the established brands in
undergraduate education are offering
something it's impossible to compete
with initially because they have uh the
brand harvard yale stanford
and they offer also this peer network uh
which is part of the reason people want
so badly to go to those places not
really the professors it's the
classmates so we don't want to compete
there initially where there is i think
room for new entrants is in
a master's program
and the first one will be
in entrepreneurship and leadership
because i think there is a huge hunger
amongst people who want to get into
particularly the technology world to
learn about those things and they know
they're not really going to learn about
them at business schools the people who
are not going to teach them leadership
and entrepreneurship are professors
so we want to create something that will
be a little like the very successful
schwarzman program in china which was
come and spend a year in china and find
out about china
we'll be doing the same essentially
saying come and spend a year and find
out about technology and there'll be a
mix of academic content we want people
to understand some of the first
principles of what they're studying
they're our first principles of
entrepreneurship and leadership but we
also want them to spend time with people
like one of our co-founders joe lonsdale
who's been a hugely a successful venture
capitalist and and learned directly from
people like him so
that's the kind of initial offering i
think there are other masters programs
that we will look to roll out quite
quickly i have a particular passion for
a masters in applied history or politics
and applied history i'm a historian
driven crazy by the tendency of academic
historians to drift away from what
seemed to me the important questions and
certainly to drift away from addressing
policy relevant questions so i would
love to be involved in
in in a master's in applied history
and we'll we'll build some programs like
that before we get to
the full
liberal arts
uh experience that we envisage for an
undergraduate program
and that undergraduate program is an
exciting one because i think we can be
innovative there too i i would say two
years would be spent doing some very
classical and difficult classical things
bridging
those old divides between arts and
sciences but then there would also be in
the second in the second half and the
junior and senior years
something somewhat more of an
apprenticeship where we'll have centers
including a center for uh technology
engineering and mathematics
that will be designed to to help people
make that transition from the
theoretical to the the practical so
that's the vision uh and i think like
any
like any early stage
uh
idea we'll doubtless tweak it as we go
along we'll find things that work and
things that don't work
but i have a very clear
sense in my own mind of how this
should look five years from now and i
don't know about you i mean i i'm
unusual as an academic because i quite
like starting new institutions and i've
done a bit of it
in my career
you got to kind of know what it should
look like
after the first four or five years to
get out of bed in the morning and put up
with all the kind of
hassles of doing it not not least the
inevitable flack that we we're bound to
take from the educational establishment
and i was graciously invited to be an
advisor to this um
university of austin and one
the reason i would
love to help in whatever way i can
is several so one i would love to see
austin the physical location flourish
intellectually and especially
in the space of science and engineering
that's really exciting to me
another reason is i am still a research
scientist at mit i still love mit
and i see this effort
that you're launching as a as a beacon
that leads the way to the other elite
institutions in the world
i think too many of my colleagues and
especially in robotics
kind of see
don't see robotics as a humanities
problem
but to me
robotics and ai will define much of our
world in the next century
and for not to consider
all the deep psychological sociological
human problems associated with that
to have real open conversations to say
stupid things to challenge the
ideas that
of how
companies are being run for example
that is the safe space it's very
difficult to talk about
the difficult questions about technology
when you're employed by facebook or
google and so on
the university is the place to have
those conversations that's right we're
hugely excited that you want to be one
of our advisors we we need a a broad and
an eclectic group of people and i'm
excited by the way that group has
has has developed uh it has some of the
some of my favorite intellectuals are
there uh steve pinker for example
but but we're also you know making sure
that we have
people with experience in in
academic leadership uh
and so it's a it's a
happy uh coalition of the willing
looking to try to build something new
which as you say will be complementary
to
the existing and established
institutions i think of the academic
world as a as a network i've moved from
some major hubs
in the network uh to others
but i've always felt that we do our best
work
not in a silo called oxford but in a
silo that that is really a hub connected
to stanford connected to harvard
connected to mit
one of the reasons i moved to the united
states was that i sensed that there was
more
intellectual action in my original field
of expertise financial history and that
was right it was it was a good move i
think i'd have stagnated if i'd stayed
at oxford
but at the same time i i haven't lost
connection with oxford i recently went
and gave a lecture there
in honor of sir roger scrutin one of the
great conservative philosophers and the
burden of my lecture was
the idea of the anglo-sphere which
appealed a lot to roger will go horribly
wrong if
illiberal ideas that inhibit academic
freedom spread all over the anglosphere
and this network gets infected with
these i think deeply
deeply damaging notions so
yeah i think we're creating a new node
uh i hope it's a node that makes the
network overall
more resilient
and
right now there's an urgent need for it
i mean there are people
whose academic careers have been
terminated
i'll name two who are involved peter
bogosian who was harassed out of
portland state
for the reason that he was one of those
intrepid figures who carried out the
grievance studies
hoaxes exposing the utter charlatan ray
going on in many supposedly academic
journals by getting phony
gender studies articles published it's
genius and of course
so put the noses out of joints of the
academic establishment that he began to
be subject to disciplinary actions so
peter is going to be involved and in a
recent uh shocking british case the
philosopher kathleen stock has
essentially been run off the campus of
sussex university in england uh for
trans uh for violating the the
increasingly complex rules about
discussing
transgender issues and
women's rights she will be uh one of our
advisors and i think also one of our
founding fellows actually teaching uh
for us in our in our first uh iteration
so
i think we're creating a node that's
badly needed those people i mean i
remember saying this to
the uh the other founders when we first
began to talk about this idea
uh to barry weiss uh and to panic and a
losses pano canalos as well as to
heather heing
we need to do this urgently because
there are people whose livelihoods are
in fact being destroyed by these
extraordinarily illiberal campaigns
against them and so there's no time to
hang around and come up with the perfect
design this this is an urgently needed
lifeboat and let's start with that and
then we can build something spectacular
taking advantage of the fact that all of
these people have
well they now have very
real skin in the game they they need to
make this a success and and i'm sure
they will help us make it a success
so you mentioned some interesting names
like heather hain barry weiss and so on
steven pinker somebody i really admire
he who was under a lot of quite a lot of
fire
uh
many reasons i admire him one because of
his optimism about the future
and two
how little of a dam he seems to give
about the like walking through the fire
there's nobody more zen about walking
through the fire than stephen pinker but
anyway you mentioned a lot of
interesting names jonathan height is
also interesting there
who is involved with this venture at
this early days
well one of the one of the things that
that i'm excited about is is that we're
getting people from
inside and outside the academic world so
we've got
arthur brooks who for many years ran the
american enterprise various
enterprise institute very successfully
has a harvard role now teaching
uh and uh and and so he's somebody who
brings i think a different perspective
uh
that there's obviously a a need to get
uh experienced uh
academic leaders involved
uh which is why i was talking to larry
summers about whether he would join our
uh board of advisors uh the chicago
a debt to the former president
of chicago and he's uh graciously agreed
to be in the board of advisers i could
go on it would become a long and tedious
list but
my goal in in trying to get this happy
band to form has been
to signal that it's a bipartisan
endeavor it is not a conservative
institution that we're trying to build
it's an institution that's committed to
academic freedom and the pursuit of
truth that will mean it uh when it uh
takes uh robert zimmer's chicago
principles and enshrines them in its its
founding charter and will make those
uh
something other than honored in the
breach which they seem to be at some
institutions
so the idea here is is to grow this
organically
we need uh rather like the academic
freedom alliance that robbie george
created earlier this year we need
breadth
and we need to show that this is not
some kind of uh
institutionalization of the intellectual
dark web uh though we welcome founding
members of that
that uh nebulous body it's really
something designed for all of academia
to provide a kind of reboot that i i
think we all agree is is needed is there
a george washington type figure who is
is there a president elected yet or is
who's going to lead this institution
hannah canelo's the former president of
st john's is the president of university
of austin and so he is our george
washington
i don't know who alexander hamilton is
i'll need you to guess
it's funny you mentioned idw
intellectual dark web have you uh
talk to your friend sam harris about
but any others he um
he is another person i really admire and
i've talked to online and offline
quite a bit for
not belonging to any tribe
he stands boldly on his convictions
when he knows they're not going to be
popular
with like he based
he basically gets cancelled by every
group he sort of he doesn't shy away
from controversy and not for the sake of
controversy itself he is
one of the best examples to me of a
person who thinks freely
i disagree with him on a few quite a few
things but i deeply admire that he is he
he is what it looks like to think freely
by himself it feels to me like he
represents a lot of the ideals of this
kind of effort yes he would be a natural
fit sam if you're listening i hope
you're in
uh i think in in the course of his
recent intellectual
quests he did collide with one of our
founders heather hying so we'll have to
model civil disagreements at the
university of austin it's extremely
important that we should all disagree
about many things but do it
amicably
one of the things that has been lost
sight of perhaps it's all the fault of
twitter or maybe it's something more
profound is that it is possible to
disagree in a civil way and
and still be friends i certainly had
friends at oxford who were far to the
left of me politically and they are
still among my best friends so the
university of austin has to be a place
where we can disagree
uh we could disagree vehemently but we
can then go and have a beer afterwards
that's that's in my mind a really
important part of university life
learning the difference between the
political and the and the personal so
sam is a i think a a good example as a
you of a certain kind of intellectual
hero
who has
been willing to
go into the
cyber uh sphere the metaverse and carve
out an intellectual
space
uh the the podcast
and
debate everything fearlessly his uh
essay was really an essay on black lives
matter and the question of police racism
was a masterpiece of 2020
and
and so he i think is a a model of what
we believe in
but we can't save the world with
podcasts good though
yours is
because there's a kind of
solo element
to this form of public intellectual
activities it's also there in substance
where all our best writers
uh now seem to be including our founder
barry weiss
the danger with this uh approach is
ultimately
your subscribers are the people who
already agree with you and we are all
therefore in danger of preaching
to the choir
i think what makes an institution like
university of austin so attractive is
that we get everybody together
uh at least part of the year
and we
do that informal interaction at lunch
at dinner
that allows
in my experience the best ideas to form
intellectual activity isn't really a
solo voyage historians often make it
seem that way but i've realized over
time that
i do my best work in a collaborative
way and and scientists have been better
at this than people in the humanities
but what really matters what what's
magical about a good university is that
interdisciplinary serendipitous
conversation that happens on campus
tom sergeant the great nobel prize
winning economist tonight used to have
these
kind of random conversations in
elevators at nyu or in corridors at
stanford and sometimes they'd be quite
short conversations but in that short
serendipitous exchange
i would have
more intellectual stimulus than in
in many a seminar lasting an hour and a
half so
i think we want to get the sam harris's
and
and lex friedman's out of their darkened
rooms
and give them a chance to interact in a
much less structured
way than we've got got used to again
it's that it's that sense that sometimes
you need some freewheeling unstructured
debate to get the really good ideas i
mean to talk anecdotally for a moment i
look back on my oxford undergraduate
experience and i wrote a lot of essays
and attended a lot of classes but
intellectually the most important thing
i did was to write an essay on the
viennese satirist karl krause
for
a an undergraduate discussion group
called the canon club and i probably put
more work into that paper than i put
into anything else except maybe my final
examinations
even although
there was only really one senior member
president the historian jeremy catto i
was really just trying to impress my
contemporaries
and that's the kind of thing
we want
the great intellectuals
the great intellectual leaps forward
occurred
often in somewhat unstructured settings
i'm from scotland you can tell
from my accent a little at least
enlightenment happened in late 18th
century scotland in a very interesting
interplay between the universities which
were very important uh glasgow edinburgh
st andrews and
the coffee houses and and pubs of uh the
scottish cities where
a lot of unstructured discussion often
fueled by copious amounts of wine took
place
that's what i've missed over the last
few years let's let's just think about
how hard academic social life has become
that
we've reached the point
that amy chua
becomes the object of a full-blown
investigation and media storm
for inviting to
yale law school students over to her
house
to talk
i mean when i was at oxford it was
regarded as a tremendous honor to be
asked to go to one of our tutors homes
the social life of oxford and cambridge
is one of their great strengths there's
a sort of requirement to
sip unpleasant sherry with the dons and
we've kind of killed all that we've
killed all that in the u.s because
nobody dares have a social interaction
with an undergraduate or exchange an
informal email in case the whole thing
ends up on the front page of the local
or student newspaper so that that's what
we need to kind of restore the
the social life
of academia so there's magic we didn't
really address it sort of explicitly
but
there's magic to the interaction between
students there's magic in the
interaction between
faculty the people that teach and
there's the magic and the interaction
between the students and the faculty and
it's it's an iterative process that
changes everybody involved so it's like
world experts in a particular discipline
are changed
as much as the students as the 20 year
olds with the
with the wild ideas
each are changed and that's the magic of
it that applies in liberal education
that applies in this in the sciences too
that's probably maybe you can speak to
this why so much
scientific innovation has happened in
universities there's something about the
youthful energy
of like young minds
graduate students undergraduate students
that inspire some of the world experts
to do some of the best work of their
lives yeah well the human brain we know
is at its most dynamic when people are
pretty young
you know this with your background in
math people don't get better at math
after the age of 30.
and
this is important when you think about
the intergenerational character of
university
the older
people the professors have the
experience
but they're fading intellectually from
much earlier than anybody really wants
to admit
and so you get
this intellectual
shot in the arm
from hanging out with people who are
circa 20
don't know but the brains are kind
of like cooking yeah
i look back on
the career i've had in teaching which is
over 25 years where cambridge oxford nyu
harvard and uh
i have extremely strong relationships
with with students
from those institutions
because
they would
show up whether it was at office hours
or in tutorials
and disagree with me
and
for me it's always been about
encouraging
some active intellectual rebellion
telling people i don't want your essay
to echo my views if you can find
something wrong with what i wrote great
or if you can find something i missed
that's new fantastic
so there is definitely as you said a
magic in that interaction across the
generations and
it's extraordinarily difficult i think
for an intellectual to make the same
progress
in a project in isolation
compared with the progress that can be
made in these very very special
communities what does a university do
amongst other things it creates a
somewhat artificial environment
of of abnormal job security that's the
whole idea of giving people tenure
and then a relatively high turnover new
faces each year
and an institutionalization
of thought experiments and actual
experiments
and then you get everybody living in the
same kind of vicinity so that it can
spill over into 3 a.m conversation well
that that always seems to me to be
a pretty potent combination let's ask
ourselves a counterfactual question next
let's imagine let's imagine that uh the
the world wars happen
but but there are no universes
i mean how does the manhattan project
happen with with no academia to take
just one of many examples in truth
how does britain even stay in the war
without bletchley park without uh be
being able to crack the german
cipher the academics
are
unsung partly sung heroes of these
conflicts
uh the same is true in the soviet union
the soviet union was a terribly evil and
repressive system but it was good at
science and that kept it
in the game not only in
in world war ii it kept it in the cold
war so
it's clear that universities are
incredibly powerful intellectual force
multipliers and our our history without
them
would look very different sure some
innovations would have happened without
them that's clear the industrial
revolution didn't need universities in
fact they played a very marginal role in
the key technological breakthroughs of
the industrial revolution in its first
phase
but by the second industrial revolution
in the late 19th century
german industry would not have leapt
ahead of british industry if the
universities had not been superior and
it was the fact that the germans
institutionalized scientific research in
the way that they did that really
produced a powerful powerful advantage
uh the problem was that
this is a really interesting point that
friedrich meinecker makes in d deutsche
caterpillar for the german catastrophe
the german intellectuals became
technocrats homo favor he says they knew
a great deal about their speciality but
they were alienated from broadly
speaking humanism and that is his
explanation one of his explanations for
why this very scientifically advanced
germany goes down the path of hell led
by hitler
so when i come back and ask myself what
is it that we want to do with a new
university
we want to make sure that we we don't
fall into that that german pit where
very high levels of technical and
scientific expertise are decoupled from
the fundamental
foundations of
of a free society
so liberal arts are there i think to
stop the scientists
making fasting impacts and that that's
why it's really important that people
working on ai
read shakespeare
i think you
said the academics are unsung heroes of
the 20th century
i think there's kind of an intellectual
a lazy intellectual
desire to kind of
destroy the academics that the academics
are the source of all problems in the
world
and i personally believe that exactly as
you said we need to recognize that
the university is probably where
the ideas that will protect us from the
catastrophes that are looming
ahead of us
is that's where those ideas are going to
come from people who who work on
economics can argue back and forth about
john maynard keynes
but i think it's pretty clear that he
was the most important economist
and certainly the most influential
economist
of the 20th century and i think his
ideas are looking
better
today in the wake of the financial
crisis than they have at any time since
the 1970s but imagine
imagine john maynard keynes without
cambridge you can't
because someone like that doesn't
actually
doesn't actually exist
without the incredible hot house
that a place like cambridge wars in
keynes's life he was a product of a kind
of hereditary intellectual elite
it had its vices
but you can't help but admire the sheer
power of the mind i've spent a lot of my
career reading canes and i i revere that
intellect it's so so powerful
but you can't have people like that if
you're not prepared to have
kings college cambridge
and it comes with redundancy i think
that's the point there are lots and lots
of things that are very annoying about
academic life
that you just have to you have to deal
with they're they're made fun of in that
recent netflix series the chair and it
is easy to make fun of academic life uh
tom sharpe's porterhouse blue did it
it's it's an inherently comical
subject
professors at least used to be amusingly
eccentric
but we've sort of killed off that
side of academia by turning it into
an increasingly
doctrinaire place
where eccentricity
is not tolerated i'll give you an
illustration of this i had a call this
morning from a british academic
who said can you can you give me some
advice because they're trying to
decolonize the curriculum
this is coming from the
diversity equity and inclusion officers
and it seems to me that what they're
requiring of us is a fundamental
violation of academic freedom because it
is
determining ex-ante what we should study
and teach
that's what's going on and
that's the thing that we really really
have to resist because that kills the
university that's that's the moment that
it stops being the magical place of
intellectual creativity
and simply becomes an adjunct of the
ministry of propaganda
i've loved
the time we've spent talking about this
because it's such a hopeful message for
the future of the university that
i still share with you
the love of the ideal of the university
so very practical question you mentioned
summer
which summer are we talking about so
when uh i know we don't want to put hard
dates
here but what year are we thinking about
when is this thing launching what are
your thoughts on this we are moving as
fast as our resources allow
the goal is to offer the first of the
forbidden courses uh next summer summer
of 2022 and uh we hope to be able to
launch an initial
uh
albeit relatively small scale masters
program in the fall of next year
that's that's as fast as is humanly
possible
uh so yeah we're really we're really
keen to get going and i think the the
approach we're taking is
somewhat imported from silicon valley
think of this as a startup
don't think of this as something that
has to exist as a full service
university on on day one we don't have
the resources of that you need billions
and billions of dollars to build a
university sort of as a as a facsimile
of an existing university but that's not
what we want to do i mean copying
copying and pasting harvard or year or
stanford would be a futile thing to do
they they would probably you very
quickly end up with the same pathologies
so we do have to come up with a
different design and one way of doing
that is to grow it organically from
something quite small
elon musk
mentioned in his usual humorous way on
twitter
that he wants to launch the texas
institute of technology and science
tits
some people thought this was sexist
because of the acronym tits
uh so first of all i understand their
viewpoint uh but i also think there
needs to be a place for humor on the
internet
even from ceo so on this podcast i've
gotten a chance to talk to quite a few
ceos
and what i love to see is authenticity
and humor is often a sign of
authenticity the
the quirkiness that you mentioned is
such a beautiful characteristic of
professors and faculty and great
universities is also beautiful to see as
ceos especially founding ceos so
anyway
uh the deeper point he was making is
showing an excitement for the university
as a place for big ideas in
science technology engineering so to me
if there's some kind of way if there is
a serious thought that he had behind
this tweet
not to analyze elon musk's twitter like
it's shakespeare but if there's a
serious thought
i would love to see him supporting
the the flourishing of austin is a place
for science technology for these kinds
of intellectual developments that uh
um that that we're talking about like
make um
make a place for free inquiry
civil disagreements
coupled with
great education
and conversations about artificial
intelligence about technology about
engineering so i'm actually gonna
i hope there's a serious idea behind
that tweet and i'm gonna i'm gonna chat
with him about it i do too i do too i uh
most of the
uh
biggest
storms and teacups of my academic career
have been
caused by bad jokes that i've made
these days if you want to make
bad jokes being a billionaire is a great
idea uh
i'm not here to defend elon's uh
twitter style or sense of humor he's not
going to be remembered for his
tweets i think uh he's going to be
remembered for the astonishing
companies that he's built and his his
contributions
in a whole range of fields
from spacex to tesla
and solar energy and i very much hope
that we can
interest elon in this project we need
not only elon but a whole range of uh
his peers
because
this takes
resources universities are not cheap
things to run especially
if as i hope we can make as much of
uh
the the
tuition uh covered by scholarships and
bursaries we we want to attract the best
intellectual talent to this institution
the best intellectual talent is somewhat
randomly distributed through society and
some of it is in the bottom quintile of
the income distribution
and that makes it hard to get to elite
education so
this will take resources
the last generation of
super wealthy plutocrats the generation
of the gilded age of the late 19th
century
did a pretty good job of founding
universities
chicago wouldn't exist uh but for the
money of that era
and so my message to not only to elon
but to all of
the peers all of those people who made
their billions uh out of technology over
the last couple of decades is
this is your time i mean and this is
your opportunity to create something new
i can't really understand why
the wealthy of our time are content to
hand their money
i mean think of the vast sums mike
bloomberg recently gave to johns hopkins
to his established institutions
when
on close inspection those institutions
don't seem to spend the money terribly
well
and in fact one of the mysteries of our
time is the lack of due diligence that
hard-nosed billionaires seem to do when
it comes to philanthropy
so i think there's an opportunity here
for this generation of very talented
wealthy people to
to do what their their counterparts did
in the late 19th and early 20th century
and and create some new institutions
and they don't need to put their names
on the buildings they just need to do
what what the founders of
of chicago university of chicago did
create something new that will that will
endure
yeah uh mit is launching a college of
computing and um
steven schwartzman is
is given quite a large sum of money i
think in total a billion dollars
and
as somebody who loves computing and
somebody who loves mit i want some
accountability
for mit becoming a better institution
and this is once again why i'm excited
about university of austin because it
serves as a beacon look you can create
something new
and this is what the great institutions
of the future should look like
and steve schwartzman
uh is also an innovator the idea of
creating a college
on the tsinghua campus
and creating a kind of roads program for
students from the western world to come
study in china was was steve's idea and
and i was somewhat involved did some
visiting
professing there
it taught me that you can create
something new
uh in that area of graduate education
and quite quickly attract really strong
applicants
because the people who finish their four
years at harvard or stanford know
that they don't know a lot
and i
having taught a lot of people
in that group know
how intellectually dissatisfied they
often are at the end of four years
i mean they may have beautifully gained
the system to graduate sumo magna
laude but they kind of know
they they'll confess it after a drink or
two they know that they gained the
system and that intellectually it wasn't
the fulfilling experience they wanted
and they also know that an mba from a
comparable institution would not be a
massive intellectual step forward so i
think what we want to say uh is here's
something really novel exciting that
will
be intellectually very challenging i i
do think the university of austin has to
be difficult
yeah um i'd like it to feel a little bit
like surviving navy seal training to
come through this program because it
will be intellectually demanding
that i think should be a magnet so
yeah steve if you're listening uh please
join elon in in supporting this and and
and and peter thiel if you're listening
i know how skeptical you are about the
idea of creating a new university
because
heaven knows peter and i have been
discussing this idea for years and he's
always said well no we thought about
this and it just isn't going to work but
i
really think we've got a we got a
responsibility to to do this well
steve's been on this podcast before
we've uh spoken a few times so i'll send
this to him i hope he does actually get
behind it as well so i'm i'm super
excited by
the ideas that we've been talking about
that this uh effort represents and
what ripple effect it has on the rest of
society so thank you that was a time
beautifully spent and i'm really
grateful for the
the fortune
of
getting a chance to talk to you at this
moment in history because i've been a
big fan of your work and the reason i
wanted to talk to you today is
about all the excellent books you've
written about various aspects of history
through money war
power pandemics all of that but i'm glad
that
this we got a chance to talk about this
which is not looking at history it's
looking at the future
this is a beautiful little uh fortuitous
uh
moment i appreciate you talking about it
you